en argentina más de 3000 mujeres
fallecieron desde 1983 debido a
complicaciones por abortos inseguros
unas cifras que afectan con especial
incidencia a las mujeres en situación de
pobreza consecuencia de su penalización
ahora los pañuelos verdes y celestes
vuelven a inundar las plazas del país al
tiempo que el debate del proyecto sobre
la interrupción voluntaria del embarazo
resurge en el congreso luego de que el
presidente alberto fernández enviara un
proyecto propio al legislativo se tratan
de dos proyectos el emitido por el poder
ejecutivo y el de la campaña nacional
por el derecho al aborto legal seguro y
gratuito
ambos se estipulan el aborto voluntario
hasta la semana 14 del embarazo más allá
de ese plazo será legal en casos de
violación y riesgo de salud de la
persona gestante como ocurre desde 1921
en el ejercicio de sus derechos humanos
toda mujer u otras entidades con
capacidad de gestar tienen derecho a
decidir voluntariamente y a acceder a la
interrupción de su embarazo hasta las 14
semanas inclusive del proceso
gestacional sin embargo difieren en la
cláusula de la objeción de conciencia
para los pañuelos verdes se trata de un
instrumento para no realizar la práctica
y piden que se legisle de forma que
prevalezcan los derechos de la mujer y
no del objeto por el lado celeste piden
no reconocer el aborto como un derecho
secula 2 por la iglesia católica y
evangelista y cuentan con el apoyo en el
senado donde la legalización de la
interrupción del embarazo quedó
sepultada en 2018